digital domain did that sequence and
it's about four square miles of fully
digital environment if you want to add
elements to miniature you need to film
those with the same motion so that they
can all pair with the shot
this is like a pretty iconic scene from
the first movie where you have all of
these like wavy horses with the horse
waves how did you get the water to look
so good what are you doing
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react today is a
very special one because we are joined
by none other than the vfx supervisor of
spiderman kelly port thank you so much
for joining us today tell me a little
bit about yourself yeah i started with
digital domain and really haven't left
digitally
but i've most recently been loaned out
by digital domain to marvel and sony
pictures for spiderman no way home where
i was the production side supervisor on
that i really can't wait to hear some of
your breakdowns your insights and your
stories i know like this is a show that
we produce but in reality it's an
elaborate scheme for red and i just be
able to satisfy our quest for knowledge
you're spoiling the secret
i can't wait to jump in let's do it
let's do it
so you did this interview with vanity
fair and in it you mentioned the movie
titanic and specifically one shot called
td35 can i get the full story on that
shot this shot ended up being a very
very expensive shot you know like
probably a million dollars why is it so
expensive well because it was our sort
of development shot meaning a lot of
things got worked out on this one shot
it was one of those big wide shots that
had a little bit of everything in it
it's got the smoke it's got birds it's
got bow wakes it's got sideways it's got
the ocean it's got sky it's got digital
characters walking around for the crowd
and the passengers it's got everything
i'm definitely noticing a whole lot in
this shot right now the key lights are
at different angles this is like right
at the very beginning the two characters
are backlit even though the sun's coming
from the right but as it goes on we see
their shadows kind of just going
directly to the right of the boat you
know just 90 degrees to the direction of
the boat and then there's like a bit of
a transition where then the shadows are
kind of going to like a 45 degree angle
backwards a little bit
and then as we keep going suddenly the
shadows are now directly backwards yeah
and it's because everything is looks
better backlit yeah
so it's a dynamic backlighting it's one
of those filmmaking techniques that just
so tried and true that just people just
don't even really notice it you know a
lot of this was early days of motion
capture early days of like all of this
kind of stuff you know film had to be
scanned all this miniature photography
we would shoot one day look at it and
dailies the next day uh call out printer
lights and things like that like oh wow
that was all very much in the film days
and even the file format was rgb just
straight rgb yeah wow like dot rgb yeah
this is before exrs were invented
this is almost before the internet
i'm really curious about the water
because you shot a miniature with a
motion control rig if you want to add
elements to miniature you need to film
those with the same motion so that they
can all pair with the shot and this is
before we could do cg simulations of
water as far as i understand so how did
you get the water to look so good what
are you doing i'm assuming the miniature
wasn't in water when you filmed it was
it no the miniature itself is about 40
feet long if you wanted to do something
like that you would have to now scale up
the move to shoot the water which is now
at a different scale so then you'd have
to have essentially a motion control
move from a helicopter
but no it's cg water for the foam waves
coming off the bow of the ship is that
like a texture that you guys filmed like
you guys film an actual wake and like
texture project that onto the water or
are you just doing a lot of fancy
texture work there that's all built into
the water surface render and then the
particles the foam it all sort of had to
be handcrafted at that point i can't
believe how good it looks like you guys
nailed it it is spot on pure artistry
just going like all right i think it's
the right color values let's go for it
that's why i had many sleepless nights
[Music]
[Applause]
so what i'm noticing here is that right
at the beginning we are seeing what has
to be the real leonardo dicaprio there
with his friend like so that's a real
shot but we're also now looking at the
miniature shot and it's a seamless
transition there so there's got to be
some degree of scaled motion control for
the camera absolutely and then maybe
even a cg takeover so what happens on a
shot like that where you start off close
and you've got the live-action actors
basically what you do is you kind of
just go around them and you do that move
as far as you can do it on the sound
stage and the track in the room that you
actually have hold the camera there at
the end and just let them continue
acting but we can't pull any further
back so at that point you're just in a
locked off camera situation and then you
just scale that image it's like a little
teeny card at a certain point that move
is scaled down to fit the miniature and
then that's programmed into the motion
control move so that's doing the exact
same move now on the miniature and then
you can overlay those interesting he
basically literally just like you 3d
tracked the scene and exported the
camera and loaded it up onto a robot arm
yes and we actually did something like
that in uh spider-man no way home
there was a shot where peter is walking
to the sanctum and he's like has his
phone and he's crossing the street
obviously the sanctum's not there we had
to replace that part of it that
intersection we went to new york put
track down shot that so on the left and
the right and across the street that's
all new york and the sanctum is digital
we had to shoot tom's side of that on
blue screen so what we did was we match
moved what we shot in new york program
that into a techno dolly which is
essentially a programmable techno crane
and then we did that move the exact same
move that we shot in new york but now
with tom uh over blue wow okay and then
we sandwich those two wow i love that
it's easy to shoot a block off plate and
shoot a blue screen later and marry
those two together but when you have a
big push in like this and dynamic
changing perspective over the course of
the shot it's a lot harder to do that so
at this point is there like a full
perfect 3d reconstruction of new york
like on the servers somewhere at digital
domain or disney or something you would
think by now i think i think so the ak
reveal sequence on that bridge digital
domain did that sequence and it's about
four square miles of fully digital
environment
trees and water and ever you name it
it's all out there and beyond that is
probably a lower resolution version it's
still 3d but just maybe more projected
but you have to have that four square
miles of high res 3d stuff because the
bridge is fairly large and the camera is
going to be in a lot of different spots
throughout that sort of area it's a big
decision up front to say okay we're
going to build this all 3d we're going
to build four square miles of 3d okay
it's a big decision and a very time
consuming and expensive decision but
knowing that the sequence is probably
going to be evolving and changing over
the course of the filmmaking process
meaning we have this new idea for a shot
we're not going to go and shoot it we're
not going to go back and shoot live
action but we have maybe additional
photography we shoot somebody on a blue
screen foreground or maybe the
continuity the edit has changed and
things have shifted around and now we're
like on the other side completely so
we're having to redo all these things
having that full 3d asset at your
disposal if you know that things are
probably going to change in these kind
of films they often it's very fluid
knowing that is i think a very smart
decision of them to sort of create that
man the best part about this part is
subscribe
thank you i appreciated that now on the
next one
subscribe oh you thought it was over no
i didn't hear you ring that bell
shame on you but oh i heard it thank you
evil is stirring in mordor
has awoken you actually worked on lord
of the rings fellowship of the ring
which i find interesting because i
legitimately thought only what a digital
worked on that movie but you were part
of digital domain at the time i'm not
sure the whole reason why they they
reached out to us but i'm glad they did
i love the sequence
water sims at this time were very very
challenging and kind of in in their
infancy and i remember these first
couple shots where the big volume of
water is coming down the canyon we
hadn't seen that kind of stuff before
and so seeing a sim like that is like oh
this is really cool
yeah this is like a pretty iconic scene
from the first movie where you have all
of these like wavy horses
horse waves the horses were animated and
then sort of rendered as water and then
you have a sort of a layer of just stuff
that murks it up you know because you
want splashes you don't want it to look
super clean and composity you know we
ended up just doing an actual plastic
render of the horses and then just
barely just sort of printing that in
because it helps sell the shape of the
horse okay sure yeah because when we
were rendering them as just regular
water they weren't clear enough is it
like more like a volume render almost
like the cloud like a like a cloud
render almost with some noise in it you
still want the overall feeling to be
that they're made out of water but if
you just do that for real all the way
it's just a water render you lose some
of that
shape what we wanted to do initially was
to scout a dam because they said they
could potentially do an emergency water
release for us we're there like almost
two hours
and the guy's like oh yeah we can't
really do that because we're having a
drought oh and we're like oh
yeah okay
okay okay so oh well what was the most
nervous you've ever been for a shot
where you were tasked with executing a
shot or supervising a shot and you had
no idea how you're gonna pull it off oh
my god i think we were really nervous
with thanos
we were quite happy with it but we knew
that we had to pull something off that
hadn't really been pulled off before
josh brolin hadn't seen our proof of
concept yet and this was the first day
of josh brolin's shooting as thanos and
they're showing it to him a few hours
before oh boy wow
so it was a little bit nerve-wracking
like i said we felt good about it but he
ended up like really liking it and i
think more than anything his takeaway
from the test was how subtle he could
play the performance typically a lot of
performers will knowing that they're
doing motion capture facial motion
capture or even body capture tend to go
bigger
because they feel like there's some kind
of filter that if they go bigger more of
their performance will come out you know
it doesn't really work that way it just
makes it look bigger and i think that
was so good that we ended up showing him
on that day because he ended up playing
the character that way i certainly
noticed a lot of that subtlety
especially like early on when he's kind
of just like you get those extreme
close-ups and you know he's got like a
little bit like a micro like squinting
of his eyes or just like a little bit of
a slight turn up of the lips for a grin
but that's the whole reasoning behind
having an actual performer drive the
ship on a character like this absolutely
and we made sure in our proof of concept
test that it was a hundred percent
unmanipulated by any kind of additional
animation on top of it this was just
okay as it came from the facial capture
directly yeah because you got to
convince him that he can be subtle about
it yeah exactly that's fascinating it
was a good story
i enjoyed your answer to that question
immensely
what's your favorite movie oh my god
i have to say the movie that most
influenced me is star wars a new hope
came out in 1977 around memorial day
weekend and so my birthday is may 26th i
was 10 years old we stood in line and
saw star wars and i was like oh my god i
don't know what that was
but i want to do that
[Laughter]
but somehow that stuck with me and uh
when it sort of came time to make that
decision of jumping back into visual
effects or jumping into visual effects
for the first time it felt so right
because it's like oh where have you been
all my life
so that was extraordinarily influential
so thank you to george lucas and his
amazing technical team at ilm for that
because here's to movies that inspire
yeah yeah
said
speaking of star wars what if
stormtroopers had good aim well we
imagined exactly what that is an amazing
video coming out tomorrow on the quarter
digital channel along with the behind
the scenes of course on this channel
make sure to subscribe to both so you
don't miss out
this video does not have a sponsor so we
are going to talk about corridor
digital.com because there's a lot of
cool things going on in that place that
i want to tell you about listen if you
like what we do here we are putting so
much effort into trying to build our own
platform that we can put whatever we
want without the algorithm gods hanging
over us like christian bale wearing
white makeup
so with the subscription what do you get
well first off you get early access to
every single video we put out usually
about a day in advance if you want to
know what's going on before your friends
do your subscription will let you be
cool and you also get a discount on all
the merch we've got the green light page
so you can actually vote on what we make
and i think that makes for the best
content because we're going to make what
we want but if you suggest something
that we also want to do we'll do that if
you enjoy this show we have extended
episodes on our website sometimes we
have these extended conversations
sometimes we go on tangents i didn't
know we're gonna take this turn on this
episode this is great either i did not
either and it doesn't really work in the
actual youtube video which are very
carefully cultivated with good pacing
and interesting story lines but
sometimes we just want to jive about
something or complain about something or
talk about something needlessly and
endlessly we got music videos we got all
kinds of stuff and that's just the vfx
artist react show on the website there's
a whole host of other shows that we've
got going on we got crew cuts if you
like the vlogs we've got like over a
hundred episodes just waiting for you to
just tap away and watch and do it all
we've got a few other shows like
functional filmmaking son of a dungeon
season one we are currently most of the
way through son of a dungeon season two
and we have upgraded the technology
across the board it's gonna be so much
better i'm excited to see the final
thing releasing in just a couple months
if you don't have the funds for our four
dollar a month subscription that's
totally okay we've got a 14 day free
trial that you can get by going to
quarterdigital.com there's a link in the
description or just simply download the
corridor app on ios or android anyway
thanks for listening to me rant about
how proud i am of our team in the
meantime thanks for watching this video
and i'll see you next saturday back to
the video
let's look that way
you still haven't cut away
now back to the video
all right quick story independence day
when the empire state building blew up
blew my mind please leave a comment
suggesting a visual effects or special
effects shot that blew your mind when
you saw it everybody thank you for
watching this episode kelly thank you so
much for joining us it's been awesome
learning from you the story's been
telling are incredible go and watch one
of those early films that inspired you
to start loving movies as well that's
our promotional request here and i will
see you guys either tomorrow for our
sunday video or next saturday if for
some reason you don't watch the sunday
videos but
whatever alright see you then